so I just finished the first season of
apples the changeling and all I can
really say is I would like to see the
baby yes Eight Episodes later and we
still don't know where baby Bryan is
what Emma's thirdd wish was or what's
behind William and kindergarten that
being said we do get some Revelations
this episode and in this video we'll be
taking a deep dive into what we know
just a reminder that I have not read the
book so there won't be any spoilers
there and as always I've left timestamps
below so you can see all the topics I'll
be covering and if you watch my
changeling videos this season consider
liking and subscribing I cover a ton of
different shows while on the island
Apollo and the women are stalked by a
giant creature that we never really get
to see Cal says this thing can swim and
at the beginning of the episode we see
its wake making its way to the island
it's heavily implied it was this
creature that helped the Norwegian
immigrants survive their journey to
North America that we saw in episode one
remember that this boat only contained
men so the thinking here is that they
made some sort of deal with this monster
in order to survive perhaps this meant
becoming Servants of it Cal says that
this one can swim implying there are
others out there and William refers to
this thing as a she judging by the
show's multiple connections to Norway
and the size of this thing we are likely
dealing with a troll at the end of the
episode we'll get this shot of Apollo in
an underground tunnel it looks like the
same underground tunnel that William
watches on his security camera does this
eye then belong to the troll I've never
seen seen a troll with a reptilian like
eye before so either the show is going
with a different type of look with their
trolls or this is a misdirect and
whatever this is isn't a troll at all
William tells us that he is called in
the calvary if you remember when he was
captured the women tell cow that he was
seen waving his cell phone toward the
shore as if signaling someone to come
over William is a part of a group called
Kindergarten 10,000 men with one name
it's this group that seems to be
responsible for stealing these children
and replacing them with a changeling a
replacement that has been glamored to
look like the original we never really
find out what motivates will to do this
nor his relationship to this
Supernatural monster that attacks the
island William also seems to have
Supernatural healing abilities having
been beaten close to death and a few
hours later totally fine we'll see his
body picked up after he's been shot and
beaten he'll survive this fight as we'll
see him monitoring some security cameras
there are a few things I want to point
out here first why is he in a room with
soundproof walls second who are these
men on the television in front of him it
looks like some sort of Zoom meeting
with each member wearing a mask they all
appear to be men will is not on camera
for this call there's no camera on him
nor is he wearing a mask this security
camera footage of a tunnel system looks
a lot like the one we'll see Apollo
Traverse we don't really know how he got
here or when in time this occurs before
leaving the island Cal tells him that
Emma went to search search for Brian at
the only forest in New York City now
when I think of a forest in New York
City I think of Central Park but Emma
has gone to Forest Park a forest located
in Queens with a historical connection
to Norway I hope Apollo can make that
distinction I should also mention this
brief shot of Apollo digging up the
grave of baby Brian only to find that
this thing is still alive and bites him
this further proves to Apollo that Emma
was right the child she murdered wasn't
theirs at all Emma's Trek to Forest Park
has led her to this Carousel There's an
actual Carousel in Forest Park but the
one seen in the show looks to be a
replica since the show was actually shot
in Toronto Emma seems to be on the right
track for if we follow the to the waters
in the wild book one must make their way
past the horses on their journey to
where the fairies have taken your child
this is as far as we see Emma make it
but if we go by the book the next thing
she'll encounter are a group of quote
guests that are dressed smartly most of
the men on William's screen are in suits
and wonder if that's a reference to them
I get the feeling we're getting closer
to the end of this book so just how
exactly they plan to turn this into
another season is beyond me to buy the
women and children more time Kalisto
climbs up this huge Rock Ledge an
astonishing feet in and of itself to
battle William she pretty much knows
she's going to die here telling Apollo
that it's her time to be with her child
for all eternity up in the stars in
Greek mythology Kalisto became the
constellation Ursa Major when Cal dies
we see a collection of stars join Ursa
Miner suggesting that she is now finally
with her child perhaps the most
frustrating aspect of this finale was
the pile of unanswered questions that
have amassed over the season we still
don't know what Emma's thirdd wish was
where Brian is if Emma's body was
swapped by the witch why William is
motivated to kill the monster what
happened to those Norwegians back in
1825 when these questions start to build
and remain unanswered it seriously
starts to take away from the enjoyment
of the show if if you want a really good
example of a show that delivers answers
while maintaining a good balance of
mystery definitely check out Apple's
Silo but now I turn it over to you what
did you think of the season finale of
The Changeling I want to hear your
thoughts and theories in the comments
below thanks for watching make sure to
like And subscribe and for more bad
takes you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram @ thinkstory YT until next
time remember I would like to see the
baby